as the first patients were released from
temporary hospitals in Wuhan City on
Tuesday there was a glimmer of hope that
China's efforts to contain the corona
virus may be succeeding reassuring
perhaps for the 50 million people on
lockdown under quarantine measures meant
to stop the spread of the disease now
known as kovat 19 the World Health
Organization has praised China's
response but it's worried it could
spread to poor countries if this virus
makes it to a weaker health system it
will create havoc it depends on how
really we lead this response and how how
we respond to the outbreak the
scientific community still doesn't know
a lot about the virus and a vaccine
probably won't be ready for another 18
months but China's leading
epidemiologist says the outbreak will
soon plateau at least in China margin
though the rate of new infections is
gradually declining according to the
analysis of our mathematical model the
epidemic will reach its peak in the
south regions after the middle of
February or in the second half of the
month but no one really knows for sure
and thousands of Kovan 19 patients are
in critical condition in the epicenter
of Wuhan experts say the incubation
period could be longer than first
thought up to 24 days before patients
show any symptoms Chinese officials have
launched a mass disinfection campaign in
cities far away from the epidemic to
keep it at bay and in Wuhan itself
patients are doing what they can to pass
the time before they too can walk out of
quarantine Andrew Chappell al-jazeera